aujourd'hui pour le calendrier de
l'avance 100 % ivinois je vous propose
une nouvelle idée de
[Musique]
cadeaux un baptême sur piste au
Vélodrome national de 50 ans iin au
programme des sensations fortes sur une
piste de 250 m de long et 8 m de large
et qui va accueillir les Jeux olympiques
de Paris 2024 avec les épreuves de
cyclisme sur piste l'occasion pour les
fans de vélo de s'essayer à cette piste
accompagné d'un professionnel l'idée de
ce bapthème est de pouvoir tester un
vélo de cyclisme sur piste et surtout
d'apprendre à maîtriser un vélo qui n'a
pas de frein et de pouvoir monter petit
à petit dans les virages oui oui tout le
monde peut y arriver ces baptèmes qui
durant environ 1 heure sont accessibles
à tous le tarif est de 39 € il comprend
à la fois le tour sur la piste avec le
baptême et également l'équipement
surtout pensez à
réserver